vladimir poutine vient donc de
s'exprimer environ quatre heures
d'entretiens avec un demi millier de
journalistes face à lui un exercice
annuel traditionnel avec cette année les
questions diplomatiques au coeur de
cette conférence de presse notamment les
dossiers de l'otan et de l'ukraine on
retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant à moscou antoine gayraud
antoine vous avez suivi les quatre
heures de questions réponses dans les
grandes lignes que faut-il retenir des
propos de vladimir poutine
oui tout à fait la conférence de presse
vient de se terminer vous pouvez voir
derrière moi les journalistes quitté la
salle et donc comme vous l'avez dit de
très nombreuses thématiques ont été
abordées mais assez rapidement plusieurs
questions abordées laquelle la
problématique ukrainienne le président
russe a constaté le manque de politesse
le manque de volonté politique de la
part de kiev à mettre en oeuvre les
accords de minsk à venir poutine a
assuré une nouvelle fois que la russie
ne menacer personne et qu'elle l'avait
en tête que d'assurer sa propre sécurité
à ce titre il averti qu'une nouvelle
extension de l'otan à ses frontières
orientales était inconcevable aux yeux
de moscou écoutez
j'ai vu qu'un des éléments principaux
aujourd'hui c'est la stabilité
sur cette partie du terrain et nous
devons comprendre comment assurer de
cette sécurité donc ici sans aucune ruse
nous avons cette question ouvertement il
ne doit y avoir aucun mouvement de
l'otan en direction de l'est c'est à
dire que la balle est dans leur camp
c'est eux qui doivent répondre
maintenant à cet égard d'ailleurs je
voudrais souligner aussi que dans
l'ensemble nous avons vu une réaction
positive
nos partenaires américains ont se sont
dits prêts à commencer des discussions
dès le début de l'année prochaine à
genève les représentants des deux
parties ont été nommés et j'espère bien
qu'on va continuer sur cette voie
le président russe a également rappelé
qu'il n'y a pas si longtemps
l'urss puis la russie coopérer
étroitement avec les autorités
américaines et moscou faisait tout pour
entretenir de bonnes relations avec
washington mais voilà les états unis
avaient apparemment d'autres idées en
tête écoutez
on aurait pu traiter la russie comme un
allié potentiel et renforcer les
relations c'était juste le contraire
c'était la tentative de poursuivre
l'effondrement et ensuite c'était
l'élargissement de le temps les merlus
mans vers l'est on a dit alors vous nous
avez promis de ne pas le faire et on ne
répond c'était pas marqué c'était pas a
mis sur papier alors on s'en fout de vos
préoccupations et sa de l'année n avait
chaque année chaque fois ont riposté on
essayait de
contredire ont présenté nos
préoccupations
0 là les besoins avec vos préoccupations
nous allons faire ce que nous voulons
faire un deux trois quatre cinq 5 vague
d'extension de le temps qu'est ce qu'on
peut ne pas comprendre je sais pas posé
cette avait posé la question je pense
que tout est clair nous ne voulons que
assurer notre sécurité
concernant cette fois la loi sur les
agents de l'étranger vous savez cette
loi qui limite le travail de certains
médias en russie et bien le dire poutine
a tenu à faire savoir qu'il s'agissait
là à la base d'une loi américaine et les
autorités les autorités russes n'ont
fait que répliquer que répondre de façon
symétrique à cette même loi concrètement
il s'agit pour ces organes de presse
simplement de déclarer leurs sources de
financement et au final il y a le nombre
de ces médias le nombre de ces médias
qui sont touchés par cette loi sont
relativement peu important je proposais
l'écouté
nous ne demandons qu'une chose c'est
d'indiquer la source de votre
financement il ya une question qui est
lié à l'implication politique ici
qui est liée à la réglementation du
travail nous avons 74 organisations qui
étaient considérés comme agent de
l'étranger sur 200 milles qui sont
enregistrés chez nous donc c'est 0 0 34%
donc on n'a même pas une rhétorique
aussi sévère que là bas aux états unis
il a également largement été question de
la pandémie et des mesures prises pour
lutter contre cette crise sanitaire des
questions là à la dimension parfois
local avec des problèmes très locaux sur
concernant telle ou telle région tel ou
tel établissement hospitalier et des
questions à la dimension nationale à
l'âme à propos des mesures économiques
et sociales qui ont été adoptées afin de
lutter contre cette pandémie de kovy 19
illégalement a également été évoqué la
crise du gaz et le rôle de gazprom dans
cette crise la dîmière poutine a rappelé
que le géant gazier russe livré tout
tous les volumes demandés
honoré tous ses contrats et elle est
même parfois au delà et livrer des
volumes supplémentaires ce qui était
peut-être le seul acteur à l'heure
actuelle sur le marché à faire affaire
ainsi de nombreuses autres thématiques
alors je vais pas toutes les citer mais
de nombreuses autres thématiques ont été
abordées telles que la démographie
l'inflation les grands indicateurs
économiques les cas particulier de la
crimée où d'autres régions russes encore
au final une conférence de presse
extrêmement dense avec des thématiques
très variées qui ont été abordés qu'ils
ont fait et malgré tout la part belle
aux problématiques nationales domestique
sur la vie quotidienne de la population
russe sans oublier de rappeler les
lignes rouges de la russie concernant
les grands thèmes d'actualité que sont
le conflit dans l'est de l'ukraine et
les relations avec washington et l'otan
merci antoine gayraud pour toutes ces
précisions et au total 55 questions ont
été posées lors de cette conférence de
presse qui a donc duré près de quatre
heures